today was a very special day for the
entire raise organization they were
presented with their al championship
rings with their last names on the side
of them kevin kiermeier the longest
tenured ray who that moment had to be
pretty special for described the ring
best when he said it's about as dazzling
as the ring could get without it being a
world series championship ring they
played a five to six minute video on the
jumbotron of highlights of that 2020
postseason run to motivate them to get
back and experience that again and as
k.k mentioned do one better and get that
other right going to the mound for them
is going to be tyler glass now sitting
right top of the zone and a cut and a
miss right up there 98
and a swing and a miss and i'll tell you
that is not fair to drop that curve ball
the change of speed
and the drop
and a swing and a miss he comes right
back dunning wasting no time and that's
kind of fitting that's how he went about
it last time
and he gets a swing and a miss so suzugo
strikes out
and to pitch to the texas catcher
and a swing and a miss at the pitch in
the dirt
white started oh for 17. his texas club
he has great speed
he lines it into center and that ball's
going to be caught sinking line drive
phillips was playing in a bit and made a
nice grab on that one
you were concerned about how quickly it
was sinking but he got there in time
there is strike three again and this
time he got him he a down looking second
strikeout
and he gets strike three called sends
adamus packing the inning is done and
the rays leave another man
swinging a miss ball bounding out toward
the mound mejia fires to first after the
pickup
and this one right by him 98 again and
he's not even trying to be fancy with
him
and then his strike three call
strikes out the side for the second time
through that's seven strikeouts
one two
and got him swinging he's talking about
an explosion onto the scene he swings
and misses
and strikes out here and dunning
cruising along nicely so far
that's the game plan against glasstop if
they can get a base one because glass
now has shown you know at times he has
struggled with the base runners and that
is strike three call dropped a breaking
ball down there on him
but now a man in scoring position
this one line to second great catch out
there as that one was
appear to be ticketed to right field
solac showing some hops a very nice
there from nick solak because that ball
was smoked off the bat
of joey wendell nick solac letting the
boys know yeah i got some ups too the
preparation is so important to be in a
position to make these plays not just
where the rangers have players lined up
but right before that pitch you saw nick
solack kind of do that infielder jump
and he's ready to
go and now a little delay on the start
and he is out
well
white cut down
and the rays
retire texas here in the fifth
glass now ahead of him two strikes
and takes care of him right there he did
go on the appeal
and a cut in a miss right back with the
hard stuff in 97 nine strikeouts against
boston 11 tonight so far against texas
and there's a wave and a miss and he
strikes out the side
and he has 13 tonight against texas
he takes care of nate lowe
[Applause]
it's going to be that one mistake and
who's going to make it well let's see if
he can make one to adamus here
will he swings and hits a high fly ball
back into left that's got carrie and is
gone
home run for the diamonds
willie adams makes it one nothing
with his second home run of the year and
how about
[Applause]
well adamus
unloads this one
we've talked about that swing plane a
little bit
and he launched that one
just enough of it
going right after that pitch down and
out over there is that high finish
uppercut swing
[Applause]
and a swing and a miss he went right
back to that fastball 96.
throws it by him and that's strikeout
number 14. well didn't really hide the
intent of what he was trying to do
through this at-bat he just continued to
pour that fastball up there top of the
zone or just above well kevin cash on
his way to the mound with two outs here
in the eighth inning and
tyler glass now has had a great night he
wants to have a little conversation with
kevin cash here i love it i love it hey
listen i wouldn't want to come out
either yep well it's been a great night
for tyler glass now he gets a great hand
and tough to come out of this game the
rays will make a pitching change
on to the ninth we go with diego
castillo
on the hill
carreras goes and stops it swinging at a
miss
and that is out number one
well you got to believe too that tavares
is trying to time up diego castillo and
he's going to go at some point and able
to take it just off the plate right off
the edge of the bat pick up that first
out
and a swing and a mess
he gets the strikeout right there
he had a lot of dip on that one
well it was a lot of sliders that dahl
kept fouling off and now he goes with
the power sinker 95 and look at that
thing take off
yeah i don't know
i've ever seen one that dramatic and
that's going to bring
nate lowe to the plate the former ray
who got off to a very hot start this
year has cooled a bit
since then is old for three tonight
and so of course it would come down to
this
here we go on the o2 to low
and he got him looking strike three call
the game is over and the rays win it one
to nothing castiol
strikes out the side gets a call third
strike to end it after giving up the
base hit and a two out walk and the
raids are winners one to nothing